hello everyone and welcome to round six
uh of the oslo esports cup it's magnus
carlson versus eric hansen we have a
very enjoyable game that's gonna be even
more enjoyable if you've seen my
previous video uh where pragananda
played against eric and they played this
well sort of a rare line of the
groomfield defense and here uh magnus
obviously enjoyed uh what he saw uh in
the game that pregnant played against
eric and he repeated the line hoping
that he would also get a fine position
so let's see what happens uh magnus with
the white pieces and they basically
repeat uh the
the the game that was played in the
previous round between eric and prague
so here's c4 g6 knight to c3 we have d5
eric again goes for the groomfield
defense c captures knight captures and
e4 chasing away the knight from d5
knight captures on c3 b captures and now
bishop to g7 so uh everything the the
same and now in the previous game uh
that we covered we mentioned that okay
you could go knight to f3 you could play
bishop e3 bishop c for rook to b1 many
many great moves but queen to a4 is uh
well it's not extremely rare but it is
rare but the move that eric plays and
that is the c6 idea this is extremely
rare so let's see how magnus uh we will
not continue knight to f3 and here uh in
the game against prague eric castle but
here he goes knight to d7 right away uh
we have bishop to e2 castles castles and
now b5 so pretty much the same yeah as
in the game against prague only now
magnus doesn't play queen to a3 and
bishop to g5 like prague played uh he
continues with queen to c2 the move that
we mentioned that um existed before
knight to b6 and now bishop to f4 and
here uh bishop to g4 are going after the
knight here and it is not as of move 12
that we have a completely new game so
magnus offers a full trade of everything
he plays knight to e5 now offers a trade
of bishops bishop captures an e2 queen
captures and eric even goes for bishop
captures an e5 and the bishop captures
an e5 now if you ask the engine about
this the engine will say okay that's a
very fine exchange but if you ask anyone
else they will tell you okay you have a
a lot of dark square weaknesses here how
are you going to
uh prevent white from checkmating you
and indeed it's not an easy task but
okay if you're confident in playing this
then you can play it knight's the c4 he
goes after the bishop and of course
magnus saves the bishop bishop to f4 the
bishop belongs on h6 uh we have queen to
a5 and now
uh rook a to c1 just guarding the c3
pawn we have f6 now trying to chase away
the bishop with the g5 so this is eric's
plan uh and the magnus now plays h4 he
says nope g5 will not be played here we
have rook 8 to d8 and now rook f2d1 uh
we have e5 now striking in the center
and it seems like uh eric solved all of
his problems but he did have to open up
his king a little bit uh magnus does put
the bishop on h6 we have rook after e8
and now queen to g4 preparing h5 to
completely bust
the king side so queen to c7 bringing
the queen to help out with the defense
and now first we're gonna play rook to
d3 if you go with h5 right away uh of
course we can just play g5 and it's not
all that impressive uh so that that will
have to wait so first rook to d3 we want
to bring the rook into the attack so
quickly queen to d7 eric wants to trade
queens as he now does have a very nice
pawn chain himself so magnus declines
this queen to g3 and now queen to e6 we
have rook to e1 aligning the the rook
with the queen nicely here and rook to
d7 just uh
adding more defense to the seventh rank
and also you can double up on the d file
if needed so magnus strikes with f4 and
here uh what do you play uh for eric the
uh the problem is you have to play uh e
captures on f4 or even you could play uh
uh e capture sunday for but he captures
an f4 is just extremely forcing and it's
very easy to find an idea with black
you're going to play knight e5 attack
the rook of course you can't capture
because the rook on d3 hangs and after
the rook moves hopefully here to help
out with the attack now you play knight
f7 attack the bishop and you've pretty
much solved your problems uh but eric
does not play that eric plays king to h8
he just wants to get the king away from
the g file
but now uh carlson's position is
completely winning and this is how f
captures on e5 as you might have
imagined f captures on e5 and now rook
to f1 now magnus will just double up on
the f file he has the bishop controlling
the f8 square and then rook to f8 will
hopefully be checkmate in some of the
lines and you can see how even though
black's position was completely fine uh
the the the mere absence of black's dark
square bishop just allows the whites to
very very quickly and easily uh mount a
crushing attack so rook to f7 uh trading
off a pair of rooks but even this
doesn't help magnus trades captures
captures and now rook f3 goes after the
queen queen e7 eric needs to keep an eye
on the f8 square otherwise he's getting
checkmated and now only now h5 so now is
the time to push it uh we have queen to
d6 and now we have queen to f2
so now as both the queen and the rook
are going after the f8 square uh you
need both your rook and the queen
guarding it so here g captures an h5 but
here magnus just played bishop to g5 and
he was in this position on move 32 that
eric hansen resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh
interestingly rook the f8 is also
winning but i guess there's no point in
calculating this if you figure out that
bishop to g5 is is winning now why this
is winning is that uh of course the
bishop to f6 is unstoppable we now have
a triple control over that square and
whatever you play let's say you play e
captures on d4 we're just gonna play
bishop f6 check and after the king moves
rogue g3 check and that's it uh you have
to go uh to the f file and even rook g7
check king e6 and queen to f5 will be
checkmate now and on the other hand
after bishop g5 if you don't play this
play something like h6 try and give your
king a little more breathing room uh
okay now uh we just go after the h6 pawn
and that's it we're gonna play rook f6
and okay you may be
thinking okay why not just give up the
bishop and the
queen
so now we have a rook and knight against
the queen maybe this is playable but
queen f6 check we're going to pick up
the
knight here and of course this is
completely unplayable
so uh bad news for eric magnus repeats
the line that uh
pragananda used to completely crush eric
uh very very successfully and he also
gets a beautiful win uh with this idea
so uh this is uh maybe a good uh
uh suggestion for you in your own games
uh even though uh uh if you analyze the
position and you're preparing for an
opponent even if you're playing a
classical game and the engine says uh
yeah i mean this is perfectly fine you
should play this uh maybe don't play it
because it will be so so much easier for
your opponent to mount the attack and uh
well unless you're perfectly
confident that you are able to pull this
off uh do not give up your
your very strong defender or attacker
depends on how you use it uh for for a
night like this because it could end
very badly and here it ended very badly
for eric uh so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by magnus uh i would like to thank
uh fred eckermann joseph verasudia
robert tarathon always crosstalk
uh and michael mcconnell for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and uh whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day